we've love Florida we're growing in
Florida left and right you know small
businesses large companies I'm on my way
to Tampa we've got you know major
operations there Orlando major
operations you are running the state you
know you should be thinking how can I
make the state off good well off my
people so Florida likes business if I
was some other states I'd be thinking
about why do people like going to these
states it's their taxes it's their Pro
business they want better life for the
people we now have more employees in
Texas than in New York state you go
there they're optimistic you're
optimistic here pro-american optimistic
Pro business no unfortunately no I I
don't know that I could have said that
better myself first off the fact that
chase now has more employees in Texas
than in New York is absolutely Wild